speaking of brash people losing their
jobs how's that for a segway
here's morgan uh piers morgan
has quit his job on good morning britain
piers morgan you know he was the the
host after larry king left cnn
then that fellow party went over to good
morning britain i kind of get a kick out
of piers morgan
he's this sort of tabloid figure
in in britain he can't really pin him
down and sometimes he's really
seems really right-wing sometimes he
seems really left-wing
so piers rightly went after meghan
markle in recent days
and uh a fellow broadcaster on good
morning britain
started viciously attacking piers morgan
about it pierce just walked offset
and i understand that you don't like
meghan markle you've made it
so clear a number of times on this
program
a number of times and i understand that
you've got a personal
relationship with mega market or had one
and she
cut you off she's entitled to cut you
off if she wants to
has she said anything about you since
she cut you off i don't think she has
but yet you continue to trash her
okay i'm done with this no no no sorry
no do you
absolutely diabolical behavior you see
i'm sorry but pierce spouts off on a
regular basis
you can trash me mate but not on my own
show
i i gotta give the guy credit for this i
got i
usually 99 times out of a hundred
storming offset looks really bad part of
the reason it looks bad is you have to
take the wires off and
you're kind of fumbling for a while you
can hear it on the mic piers i guess was
wearing a wireless mic i don't know
about the earpiece that he had in
but he did it so gracefully he's sitting
there kind of taking very you know
british just taking his
taking the licks you know and then the
guy's going you and you
she cut you off yeah and she yeah you're
a jerk you know and you're trashing her
and and he's just doing this okay bye
see ya
just walk so upset the reason i find
this of any interest
to our political questions here is
because for a long time the right in
this country not the left but the right
has espoused this idea that
we should always just engage in the free
marketplace of ideas we shouldn't know
we should just take
any sort of criticism that's good that's
fine because eventually the good ideas
are going to win out and that's
totally cool we're anti-censorship right
you know we love free speech and so what
pierce did is
sort of opposed to free speech because
he just walked walked off the set
i think he's actually showing us
something valuable here
we are under no obligation because of
our love of free speech
or civil discourse we are under no
obligation to engage
in bad faith conversations
and bad faith debates what was going on
on good morning britain it was not a
good faith debate i was not you know
piers i don't think it's right for a
newsman to say this sort of thing about
the
princess or the ex-princess and i think
this was very
personal it was not in any way intended
to persuade
or to and this guy i don't think was
willing to be persuaded he was saying
yeah she cut you off
loser yeah she yeah you're she's cooler
than you you're not cool
yeah and so you and you're a jerk about
it too and he just says oh oh this is
what we're doing okay well i have no
no reason to engage in that i think
conservatives ought to do that a little
bit more
the left does it to great political
effect but what do we do we
conservatives we just always we go back
on the left-wing news shows
we have the left-wing news out let's
moderate our debates we just got the
news yesterday
from the rnc debate commission that
they're not going to have left wing out
let's moderate the republican
presidential debate
good finally we're understanding this
we're understanding that a free
marketplace of ideas
in that sort of marketplace people have
to set the rules of the marketplace
and if we're going to engage in commerce
we can't engage in fraud we want to
engage in good
faith commerce here both in you know in
the economic marketplace and also
in the marketplace of ideas if you
enjoyed that break from disinformation
historical revision
and screaming about the end of the world
be sure to hit the subscribe button
so that you never miss another video